well everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast implementation of genomic
assays for tumor profiling in a clinical
laboratory setting presented by dr. Sara
Marie we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
group for more information please visit
lab roots com my name is huge fan and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of your
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen or answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right finally you have trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you're having a problem now I'd
like to introduce our speaker dr. Sara
Marie dr. murray is director of genomic
technology at UC San Diego center for
advanced laboratory medicine a professor
in the department of pathology at the
center for advanced laboratory of
medicine dr. Murray is involved with the
development of advanced genomic
technologies for clinical lab and
oversees the bioinformatics and analysis
of genomic data prior to coming to us
CSD she was a founding member of the
Scripps translational Science Institute
serving us Institute's director of
genetics as long as associate professor
of translational genomics at the scripps
research institute institute from 2003
to 2007 dr. murray was the chief
geneticist at illumina a San Diego
genomics biotech company where she
played a large role in developing the
content of the design strategy for
numerous whole genome whole genome
genotyping assays at an equal
large-scale genome wide genetics
dr. Maria has a long history in both
theoretical and applied genetic research
she received her PhD from the University
of Pittsburgh's Department of Human
Genetics and with the puss a fellow at
Case Western Reserve Department of
Genetics vector Marie also holds an
mastering the Science degree in genetic
counseling from the University of
Pittsburgh please join me in welcoming
dr. Murray and then I'll turn over the
presentation to her
hi thank you so much for inviting me
I hope they have the slides up for
everyone to see um okay thank you so
much for inviting me to give a
presentation about some of the clinical
testing that we're doing here at UCSD in
the field of tumor profiling um so today
I'm going to talk to you about our
efforts in bringing precision medicine
to cancer diagnosis and treatment using
various genomic tools as you may or may
not recall the first draft of the human
genome was announced in two thousand at
that time President Bill Clinton made
his announcement at the white house with
great fanfare with Francis Collins and
craig Venter the announcement held great
promise that cracking the genetic code
would bring improvements to many areas
of medicines 15 years later on which was
last year President Obama announced his
presence at precision medicine
initiative in his State of the Union
address at the time the figure on the
top right of this slide is awarded about
this new initiative and you can see that
there lots of words that are highlighted
that have been used many times
describing this new initiative things
like genomic health tools information
medicine and care and so what I'm going
to talk to you today is about some of
the tests that we've developed that
encompass many of these concepts to help
diagnose and deliver the best care for
cancer patients so I'm going to talk to
you a bit about how genomics can be used
in the management of cancer the idea is
that you develop a panel of clinically
actionable genes as a test we can then
sequence the tumor samples from patients
and then identify which of those genes
have clinically actionable mutations
that are potentially the driver
mutations for the tumor to do this we
sequence DNA derived from the patient's
tumor we can also sequence DNA derived
from a source that representative of the
patient's inherited or germline genome
such as blood and that's typically what
we use having the inherited genome aids
and the interpretation of the data but
it isn't necessary we use
various by automatic tools that I'll
talk about a bit later about how we can
get around that but it's always better
to have the paired sample as possible
and then by identifying mutations that
are unique to the tumor we can then
drill down to determine which of those
are the driver mutations and all of this
is really to have a better understanding
as a unique molecular signature of the
tumor to help us both refine a diagnosis
prognosis and also help to aid them
determining what the most efficacious
cancer therapy may be for that patient
based on the genes or pathways that are
altered in the tumor so this table shows
some examples of genomic alterations and
the respective therapies to target those
genomic alterations and these are
classic examples and many of these
alterations actually don't need the
latest genomic tools to test but use
plastic cytogenetic techniques such as
fish fluorescence and cider
hybridizations or simple Sanger
sequencing but this list is ever growing
with better understanding of cancer
biology and news therapies and this is
where advanced genomic tools can be used
to test more broadly across numerous
games at once but these ones we actually
typically still do in the lab in a
cytogenetic slot in particular the first
example amplification of erbb2 or the
protein her to mrs. a classic test
that's done on pretty much every breast
cancer sample to see if a patient is
amenable to Herceptin with targeted
targets her2 amplification there's the
very classic Philadelphia chromosome the
translocation between chromosomes 9 and
22 that creates this BCR Abel fusion
protein that its target for gleevec
which is often seen in CML patients and
also some other leukemias as well other
great examples or mutations in egfr gene
for non-small-cell lung and the therapy
there is part Eva and other examples
b-raf mutation for melanoma alch fusion
which is actually really interesting
more recent finding
by pfizer and it has the valkyrie
therapy that actually targets this
fusion seen in non-small cell lung
cancer as well the reason why this
example is an interesting one is they
actually use this alterations in the
very beginning of their approval process
for their drug and so the drug actually
went through all fda approval at record
pace really because they had designed
their trial encompass in this genomic
alteration so these are just some
examples and the last one on this table
is actually not having a mutation in the
K raff gene to make someone more
amenable to the therapies to talk to
Matt and other related therapies sorry
to side us how to supply their um so
this slide then shows kind of overall
scheme of how we carry out this tumor
profiling so we have our tumor which is
a representative the somatic genome and
again we like to get a peripheral blood
sample as possible and we sequence on
our panel genes which I'll talk in more
detail please identify these unique
driver mutations and based on that
potentially we have different treatment
options but that alone is not what
informed treatment options we look at
tumor pathology and radiology the
patients prior response to therapies in
the medical history and all of this
helps to inform what the best therapy is
for that patient sometimes based on the
molecular signature it's an fda-approved
therapy for the tumor type sorry I'm
overcoming a cold and my voice is going
hopefully it'll hold out I'm sorry
excuse me sometimes the alteration has
an FPGA approved therapy but it's for
different tumor types and so that would
be considered off-label use for
different therapy types and often these
signatures are helpful to put a patient
on a clinical trial for new therapies
based on the genomic alteration
I'm going to talk now a bit about the
panel that we just designed and
implemented as a clinical test here at
UCSD many of our oncologist here had
been using the foundation one test and
so we started with their gene list as a
starting point because we knew they
liked their content and so we we thought
we would include all of that on earth so
then we added some additional content we
then went through the cancer gene
database census database from cosmic and
we identify genes that were mutated at
least three percent of various tumor
types including kind of the more
commonly solid tumor types like long
rest skins GI CNS and prostate from this
search we came up with a hundred and
eighty-seven gene some of the genes on
this list overlaps with the foundation
one list so in total we came up with 397
genes total and for 28 of these genes so
for all of these genes we target just
the exons so we look at them all of the
protein-coding regions for all of these
397 genes for 28 of these genes we
actually targeted both introns and exons
because these were genes that have been
identified that were a fusion partner
with another gene that is thought to be
a driver of cancer and so I given an
example the previous slide about some of
the occasion that are known target and
there are many others as well for very
solid tumor types and so we for the 28th
genes and we decide capture probes that
go across introns and exons because
often the brakes and these fusions do
occur in the introns so in total we have
390 17 on our panel encompass all the
coding regions so this next slide is
tough to see because it's very dense but
it gives you an overall sense of that
there's just a lot of content on our
panel so these are all the 397 jeans and
the subset at the bottom of this slide
is the set of expanded capture that are
involved with rearrangements and very
solid tumor types
so our lab is both a clia-certified lab
and also cat certified lab and so in
order to create a test it's going to be
used on patient samples you have to the
tests have to be conducted of course in
a CLIA lab and then you also need to
create the test it's called a lab
developed test they're also FDA approved
test but for the most part most NGS
based sequencing tests are all lab
develop test and so as part of that
process of creating a lab result test we
need to run a validation study to
demonstrate things like accuracy and
precision and limits of detection etc
and the validation study also helps to
establish what the reportable ranges are
in various quality metrics and various
processes of how we carry the whole
thing pull test out in the test
development process we also developed
our library library prep method which
was released cap a library prep system
with Agilent shirt select capture probe
excuse me my voice is going again and
it's been optimized for low input
amounts of DNA that's been derived from
ffpe so that those DNA are always
degraded some more degraded another so
we needed to optimize the process that
is minimal to low input cna and also
degraded DNA we also have have custom
development of our bioinformatics
pipelines for all of the whole process
from pretty much coming off with the
sequence series through to the end and
so the greed alignments and variant
calling for all types of variations
single nucleotide variants and in dells
and deletions and also gene
amplification and also the gene fusions
from from those 28 genes we look for
lots of annotation lots of to see
metrics that we look for we do a lot of
database lookups to help determine if
variant is somatic or germline if we
don't have that pair
germ-line specimen so based on all of
the validation process we came up with
quality metrics our average depth of
coverage is about 16 third I'm sorry six
hundred fold across all of those exons
of all of this 397 genes and the minimum
depth of coverage is 100x so we only
will call a variant if it's represented
by at least 100 reads at that base and
in our validation study we compared
variants that were called by a different
clinical test versus the one that we are
developed in-house and we had a hundred
percent accuracy in detecting those
variants and so we felt their good about
going live with this test and just to
comment on the types of alterations that
we detected again from the validation
study we came up with limits of what we
can detect based on losses limits of
detection types testing so for single
nucleotide variants these are things
like 'no sense or nonsense flights
mutations we will call down to five
percent variant frequency we actually
can go lower because we've sequence at
such high depth of coverage but with it
being ffpe we also find it gets to be
that noisy below five percent we call
insertions and deletions either coding
frameshift and in frame mutations and we
also go down to the same five percent
variant frequency for those variant
types we can call geniuses vacations if
they're at least nine copies or higher
we can also call homozygous gene
deletions and then again we can call it
these rearrangements or fusions they do
need to be represented pretty well in
the genome in the tumor I'm sorry by at
least twenty five percent depending on
what the fusion is sometimes they
actually need to be a bit higher but
with some of the more common fusions
we're comfortable about down to about
twenty-five percent so the sample
requirements we have to work with how
the process is done
in research I always would like to work
with fresh tumor but that's not really
within the clinical workflow there are
reasons why tissues are fixed in ffpe
there's a lot of histology and a lot of
you know work to evaluate is this
actually a tumor and you want to make
sure what you're asking is tumor and so
there is a lot of utility and going from
an ffpe block so we can actually get the
blocker we can get slides but we do need
to have at least twenty percent tumor
represented sometimes we get samples
below that and we'll try but we're
always with a caveat that if we don't
find any tation it's not that it's not
there it's just there's probably not
sufficient to my material to find it and
we also need sufficient cellular
material for 100 nanak about hundred and
grams of DNA we are as it can go below
that but that's typically what we like
to start with and all tumors are tumor
types can be different there's different
makeups depending on what the tumor type
is like and so you can't say you need
you know ten microns scroll from every
tumor every time are different
representations so generally we have
some guidelines but we just need
sufficient material for about 180 gram
we recommend again getting that optional
peripheral blood sample and it helps to
determine if it's a somatic or an
inherited variant we always caution that
it's not supposed to represent or
replace a germline test like a bracha
one or two tests but certainly we can
find those incidentally and so because
of that we actually are putting in place
a consent so that patients know before
they go into the test even though we're
looking at your tumor with even with or
without the blood sample sometimes we
come across variants that we can tell
our germline in their cancer
predisposing like a bracha one or two
mutation that they're aware of that
because it has implications of course
for them but also their family members
and we want to make sure they're getting
the proper follow-up genetic counseling
and everything like that so we are
working on putting a consent
place we realized it's important we have
come across as a handful of times
already have so it's important thing to
keep in mind okay so I'm going to talk a
bit now about our overall process I
won't go on to the nuts and bolts of our
bio informatics pipeline but just to
kind of give you an overview probably do
things our pipeline is again we images
are converted to base calls on the
instrument and we use the alumina
high-stake 2530 sequencing part and we
generate pare down 100 based I reads and
so the base calls are then leave large
collection of base call files and we
transfer them all over to our server we
have our own server that's dedicated to
this test and we'll to our all of our
NGS based tests and it sits behind a
firewall of our Medical Center we can't
use cloud shared resources or anything
like that because it has to be HIPAA
compliant and everything and part of its
Medcenter policy and part of it is just
general good practice for clinical
testing so we have our large collection
of reeds and so we align the reeds using
bwa which is very common Reed alignment
tool then we call our variants are
single nucleotide and insertion or in
dells are called using a somatic
variants collar and we also can do use
gatk for some local realignments for in
dells that's generally what our process
is for the best variant calling so that
part is actually worked out quite well
and sorry that this is may not be
showing up hard to read the dark letters
on the colored background in this figure
so I will read them to you so the we
will only carry forward variants that
are a frequencies at least five percent
in the depth of coverages at least 100
we actually go through and we
any position that falls below 100 x not
across every basic captured but across
every variant that's in cosmic with at
least five samples we flag to make sure
that we are aware because we don't want
to not call a piece of d3 mutations
because you had low coverage even though
overall you had good coverage on your
runs at that particular base fell short
we actually make sure that we cover all
clinically important variants that are
known by at least 100 x and if it falls
below we can fill it in with the Sanger
essay or distribute repeat the run so
then we do annotation to determine what
the variant type is missense mutation
and nonsense mutation branch shift and
frame slice mutation and also those gene
amplifications and deletions or chain
fusions we do a lot of lookups with
population databases exact which is out
of the road which is you know 10,000 or
actually more than that individuals so
if it's found in that database that a
frequency of one percent or more or and
we also do book in thousand genomes it's
probably a polymorphism and not a
somatic mutation we then also look at
cancer databases we look in cosmic and
see by our portal and see has this
mutations been the president neither one
of those databases we do in silico
predictions to predict if the mutation
is predicted to alter the resulting
protein and we use sift and polyphen and
mutation assessor for that we also do
lookups with clinvar which is NCBI
wonderful tools or inherited inherited
mutations for inherited diseases and
this is really helpful when we see a
bracket mutation or even some of these
other genes that are canted predisposing
since the Lynch syndrome genes for
example so we'd look to see if this
mutation is in clinvar and how is it
classified is it classified as a
pathogenic variant or is it possible
benign or variant of unknown
significance that's actually very
helpful too and so we can do all of this
in a relatively automated streamlined
way in our pipeline but then when it
comes down to what we want a report
there's this little line between report
right above it it's called literature
and we do a lot of that is not automated
and that's myself and dr. John Thorson
whose molecular pathologists with us we
just go through the literature and we
look and see do we think that this is
something that really is clinically
relevant or is this something we're not
quite so sure about so help determine it
is it a clinically significant variant
or we're going to report this as a
variant of unknown sir and so that kind
of brings to the next slide about the
decision of what to report so reportable
variants again we will only report
things that are clinically significant
or likely significant we will confirm
all of those variants with a Sanger
sequencing assay and that actually is a
lot of work but it's important to do
when you know physicians are going to be
making treatment decisions based on that
and so these tend to be very well
characterized somatic variants may have
multiple publications or very well-known
functional domains things like the wrath
k wrasse mutations p53 etc and then
depending on the tumor types they're
also often many other genes but they're
known to be frequently mutated in this
tumor type these also can be variants
that are reported multiple times in
cosmic group C vile and it predicted be
damaging then the third class or those
inherited mutation that are on the
American College of medical genetics and
genomics list so they've come out with a
list of 56 genes that if you find
mutations at the genetic mutations in
these jeans they recommend you return
the results back to the patient even if
that was not the intent of the original
test and that again is really what has
driven us to put a consent form in place
with it for our test so these are genes
like right now
stoma rat a PC and of course bracket one
and two and all the Lynch syndrome genes
then we'd also have variants of unknown
significance these are novel recorded in
a few samples they're likely to be
somatic have some prediction of being
damaging but there's just no literature
there's no information about them we
think they're probably important but
there's just not enough evidence until
we put them in that bucket of the V us
and then what we don't report or
non-coding variants through synonymous
variants and we are common confirmed or
likely germ line coding mutations that
have benign functional predictions we're
going to polymorphisms and there are a
lot of those we're all very polymorphic
but most of those supports have nothing
to do with the tumor itself so this next
slide shows what our report looks like
it's kind of hard to see this is
actually the first page of our report
from an actual patient we removed a
identifying information for this slide
so we worked with our oncologists
determine what they really wanted in the
report and so really you know what's
most important is on page one having a
summary of what the clinically
significant variants are as well as the
measured variant frequency in the tumor
specimen to see how represented this
mutation is in the tumor that could be
very informative and then again really
what's important is what the potential
therapies and trials may be and we
partner with the company n of one for
the information regarding what the
relevant therapies and trials are and
then the subsequent pages the report
have a more detailed description of the
clinical evidence the gene function and
again it's more information about the
various therapies and trials our test is
ordered in our hospital information
system our electronic medical medical
record which is called epic and that's
where our reports then appear back there
so a physician can order and get the
reports back all within the electronic
medical record system that we have our
target is that we have a turnaround time
about 16 days from receiving the block
to the return of results sometimes it's
quicker
and sometimes it's a little longer but
that's what we shoot for if it's an if
the block is an internal patient it can
be very quick when the order happens if
it's an outside patient sometimes
patients have had their surgeries
somewhere else in there then they come
to UCSD they change they loop their care
to UCSD or it's there for a second
opinion for example we'll have to get
the block from an outside facility and
that support boys at the time but
generally we try to shoot forward 16
days will actually receive the block so
this is a pie chart of what we've
actually seen to date so we started we
went live with this test about last June
it's mid June or so so we haven't been
up for quite a year but we're close to
it and to date we have reported a
thousand clinically significant variance
this is from about 78 jeans on average
I'm sorry we reported thousand variants
to date i'm looking at my note to myself
about 350 of clinically significant but
a thousand total variance so that the
thousand includes both a variant of
uncertain significance as well so on
average for patient we see to clinically
significant and three variants of
unknown significance the bed of course
is arranged sometimes we don't find any
and sometimes we find a lot and not all
of our 397 genes are created equal what
about less than 100 are really well
understood enough to provide a
clinically significant result many
instances where were we've been able to
provide clinically significant results
to patients that would have been
detected in our 47 gene panel that we
validated a few years ago so that one
was very good so our oncologist here
really wanted more data they wanted span
of content which is really what drove us
to create this test and we have actually
found that having expanded content
has been helpful that we actually are
finding things in a jeans outside of
that corset that we started with that
have been useful in terms of informing
um better care for the patients the
distribution here actually reflects the
fact that about half to about two-thirds
of all of the samples that we we test
our brain cancers we sequence and run
DNA microarrays on every brain cancer
that comes through here through UCSD we
also profile a lot of the
gastrointestinal GART carcinomas like
gastrointestinal stromal tumors just
colon as well as other common unit
breasts long melanomas we also do a lot
of I cancers uveal melanoma and then the
cord from any other solid tumor type the
most frequent gene that we see mutations
in is of course p53 and that's very
common finding a lot of a lot of cancer
types or feed of duty mutations occur in
minicamp cancer types mutations in genes
of a TRX and idh1 cdk and a 2a and 2b
nf1 and two are ones that are seen and
various brain tumors a gliomas and then
angiomas egfr amplifications are also
seen in glioblastoma and when we also
see egfr mutations and lung cancers and
the racks often seen of melanomas and K
rest mutations energy I tumors but kind
of gives you is flavor of what we see
and it kind of is reflected two types of
cancers that we look at so I'm going to
just spend a little time here to talk
about focus more on how we are profiling
all the brain cancers that come through
UCSD we use both two different
technologies actually 22 sa each brain
tumor we use our NGO panel that I just
talked about we also use DNA microarray
and this really helps today goes googly
on us and so we've done about 200 brain
cancers to date and we started probably
two years ago so at least when we
started doing this again with our
smaller 47 gene panel with the
microarray and
last year we have changed to our bigger
panel and this slide shows an important
paper from the Campo Genome Atlas group
that came out about a year ago in the
new england journal of medicine and it
describes the hallmark side of genetic
and molecular findings in gliomas and it
really helps to provide guidance
regarding tumor grade in both
cytogenetic and molecular profiling a
very integral in diagnosing and staging
gliomas and actually becoming part of
the wh of guidelines for diagnosis and
staging of gliomas and so this is a
great figure from that from the paper
that just shows how mutations and then
cytogenetic findings really can help put
the diagnosis in two different buckets
primarily what we're looking at idh
mutations that we're looking for the co
deletion of chromosomes 1p and i think
you and then certainly other mutations
as well go into that and so important
thing to think about and remember is the
type of genomic alteration depends on
where the area errors occur in a cell
cycle and so that's why we'd like to do
this integration of sequencing and DNA
microarray data because we are looking
at both single based changes which are
errors in synthesis DNA synthesis and
then we're looking and aired in cell
division which happens in mitosis
different areas of the cell cycle and so
you know you can use different
technologies for you can use an NGS to
look at all of these but it's not one
size fits all I think NGS tests have
their strengths but I think DNA
microarrays are also really helpful I'm
going to kind of show you some examples
of that but to give an example we often
you again we see mutations in p53 if you
can see this knit microarray that one of
the homologs is either deleted it is a
copy neutral event it's happened like
loh and that can render
mutation to completely knock out the
whole gene function you may not get that
from the NGS alone and so both of them
are really helpful with the
interpretation especially also highly
complex genomes like metastatic
adenocarcinoma their whole ability to
from mitotic mitotic cell division has
gone completely haywire so those is the
most complex sound genome and so it's
helpful to have an understanding of that
when actually even interpreting the
variant data mutation data as well so
i'm going to talk just a few words about
the stick microwave platform that we run
we use the affymetrix uncle Stan
platform for all of our solid tumor it's
in a molecular inversion probe assay and
it works very well for degraded DNA
again we're using FFPE samples so
instead of a targeted 400 genes this is
actually genome-wide detection of copy
number alterations not a highly dense is
what you would use for a constitutional
like arrays on inheritance Tina genomes
but it's actually works very well for
these cancer genome and they've actually
higher density probes in and around 900
camp Eugene we can detect down to about
ninety 25% to more content and our NGS
are lower than its twenty percent that
they're both pretty similar the done and
dynamic range is very good it goes from
zero having a homozygous deletion up to
gene amplification so 50 copies or more
so it's you know definitely the
different biology and treatment
implications between oh I know what it's
going to say here sorry I think it's
really important to be able to call gene
amplification accurately and like I
mentioned from its talking through the
NGS data we can call nine copies or
greater we kind of use very stringent
cut off I've seen other gene NGS
clinical tests out there that
incorrectly call a gene amplified when
in fact is just a single copy gain
across the whole
of them are for chromosome armor
segments and there's definitely
different biology and treatment
implications between a tree
amplification versus the tribes manin so
we really find it very helpful to have
the DNA microarray data with our NGS
data to help discern that especially for
very complex genome um so just to point
out what some of the hallmarks
cytogenetics findings are for various
stuff most common tumor types that we
see so those with glioblastoma which is
pretty nasty tumor types very hallmark
finding is it tries to meet chromosome 7
so a gain of chromosome 7 a loss of
chromosome 10 or just a deletion of 10 q
EGR egfr amplification egfr is located
on chromosome 7 and then p10 loss which
p10 is actually on chromosome 10 so when
you lose chromosome 10 years losing p10
and then you got to see a homozygous
lots of cdkn2a and to be and for auto
good under glioma which is a more
favorable prognosis again hallmark
finding is co deletions of chromosome 1
P and 19 q I'm just going to show you a
couple examples of what microarray data
looks like in cytogenetics is very
visual is harder to show visually the
NGS data cuz it's lots of numbers but
this is a figure of what we see and it's
hard to see but Jax is actually a
smattering of all of those 220,000 snip
so each dot is a snip and so this is it
all plotted out into one graph and so
what's starting from the left that's
chromosome 1 going all the way to the
right through chromosome 22 and then the
bigger blue at the very far right is the
X chromosome and at the top is a measure
of intensity and so the line that goes
across all the way through the middle is
diploid and anything that drops below
that is a deletion I think it goes above
that is its duplication and then below
is looking at a measure B allele
frequency so randomly any snip can be
ay ay ay ay B or B be so we look to
seize the PLO frequency at that
particular snip is at zero one half or
one and so if it were up to your
population of cells that were there's a
deletion we see to be a little frequency
being zero or one but because this is a
tumor and it's not a pure population of
cells we see some kind of intermediate
and the closer the be a little frequency
is to 0 or 1 means the higher percent of
all tumor cell is actually deleted in
this case it's actually probably about
80 or so percent but this is a very
homework finding of again
oligodendroglioma just circled the loss
of 1p and then the code deletion of loss
was 19 q this is very clean very simple
this is the only cytogenetic
abnormalities we detected and it's um
and this is again a common finding in
all ago gender and this is a predictor
of chemotherapy responses and better
much better prognosis than a
glioblastoma we also did a molecular
profiling and found the IDH mutation
which again falls within this whole
classic findings that you find together
here's an example of glioblastoma and
this is classic diagnostic findings here
we see again that gain of chromosomes 71
if you can see with that arrow there's a
spike and that's the egfr implication
and often many many copies of 30 or more
it depends but if it tends to be pretty
highly amplified we also see a loss of
chromosome 10 in this case you can see
here there's actually bigger drops than
just a single deletion annexed the
homozygous loss of the gene cdkn2a and
to be and then we also can see I didn't
point out but there are other
alterations and often you can see
additional alterations in addition to
that we did the molecular profiling we
actually found a p10 mutation so that in
addition to the chromosome 10 loss this
renders all of pecan function has been
knocked out so this of course is the
very unfavorable finding so but the
classic finding for what we've seen
glioblastoma the last example i'm going
to give you here is
is this a single major finding that we
found and actually this was in an infant
and the tumor was originally thought to
be a primitive neuroectodermal tumor
which has about a fifty percent
five-year survival rate we ran this on
the microscope microarray we actually
also ran it on our NGS essay and the
only thing we found for both assays with
this homozygous deletion of this gene
smart be smart be one and it's a really
unfortunate finding it's the most
frequent alteration observed and rad
Lloyd tumors and those are very
aggressive in a very poor prognosis so
very sad finding for this infant but it
did actually change the diagnosis and
actually change the overall strategy of
how they're going to treat this patient
so just left but I think or a second to
last slide here just to point out that
the genomic assays alone can't make
treatment decisions for patients the
whole process really requires a
multidisciplinary approach we've a
monthly narrow molecular tumor board we
have representatives from neuropathology
cytogenetic clinical genomics their
oncology and radiology and even genetic
counseling at time to discuss the cases
and it's been an invaluable experience
in figuring out the best diagnosis and
approach for numerous cases and
especially the a typical ones and it's
also been a wonderful learning
opportunity for all of us I think I
learn something every time and it's also
great for training for all of our
residents and fellows and trainings that
we have to so just some final comments
the molecular tumor profiling is quickly
becoming a standard of care and some
timber types it's becoming integrated
into the w/e take up guidelines for
glioma the expanded panels can provide
an additional information regarding the
overall mutation burden and tumors and
also made a technic Asians and rare but
clinically significant genes so some
things that you may miss and make more
focused smaller panels um expand of
panels have a longer the u.s. list
because a lot of the genes on there
actually they're interesting
but they're really not well
characterized clinically so but you know
we learn as we go so the more we do the
more we learn and so eventually you know
things can get moved from a V us into a
clinically significant category and we
really find the DNA microarrays
complement the NGS testing by providing
a overall context with the tumor genome
complexity and that's been really really
helpful especially in these brain cancer
cases we have just finally I'd like to
thank my department of pathology here at
UCSD my chairman dr. Steve Jonas and
head of the clinical labs here dr. bond
mcclung and then our clinical molec ARB
sorry I molecular pathologist dr. John
ports and how they work very closely
with on all of these endeavors and our
clinical genomics staff she like son is
our bio informatics scientists who
really just kind of outstanding job
point I plan together and then Dave
Brown is our guru in the lab and then
where clinical cytogenetics Saito
genomics lab will work very closely with
for the microarrays my by dr. Marie de
la cola and join up is our guru and the
micro arrays in the lab and it's all I
have and so happy to take questions that
was fantastic thank you so much dr.
Murray for bringing that information to
us but it's now time for the question
and answer session and I'd like to
remind the audience of how to submit
questions we have a question that you
would like to ask dr. Murray please
click on the green Q&A button located
the lower left of your presentation
window type your questions in the box
that appears on the screen and click the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so it
looks like we have a couple great
questions already so let's get started
the first question comes from G at the
cchs NC who asks how and why do you
define the nine copies that are needed
to call Jeannie qualification that's
that's a great question um actually a
gene amplification asst is fewer than
nine copies using like her to guidelines
anything that you can do by ratios if
it's a
alone i believe it's 45 25 copies are
higher but when we did our validation
study we were not comfortable that we
could reliably call every time an
amplification unless there were nine
copies or more so that's why we decided
to put that threshold so if there is a
gene amplification of six or seven
copies we probably won't be able to call
it and it's not that it's not there it's
just we don't reliably think that we can
rely they call it that's why I actually
we really like having the DNA microarray
with it because I can call very you know
the whole dynamic range goes all the by
copy you know 0 up to 50 let's go but
that's how we drive that great next we
have a question from Helen at the
University of Manchester and she has how
often do you find inherited cancer
predisposition mutations in patients
without a family history that's a great
question to we've only probably found a
handful one very interesting case was a
gentleman who was actually in a car
accident and because so they had imaging
and he found out he had a hemangioma and
so we did tumor profiling on it and
didn't find anything somatic but i found
a vhl deletion the for von hippel-lindau
syndrome which is an inherited so we
actually an hour i actually met with him
with a counselor and he's actually
having testing done for his children so
it is an interesting you know that
doesn't happen a lot we thought i've
only probably had a few cases of that
usually there is a strong family history
and so that sometimes you dig enough in
the chart you actually see that they
actually already knew that but they
forgot or whatever but usually there is
actually a strong family history that
case i just mentioned actually there was
with no family history i'm very
interesting next we have a question from
roger varman at the kdh and yes how for
validation of somatic panels do we need
both norm
and tumor tissue or only the tumor
tissues yeah that's a great question so
we prefer to have those we validated it
both ways so if we don't have a paired
sample we rely on population databases
to see if the variance is husband seen
if it's you know been seen it all in the
general population is probably a
germline and then of course the variant
frequency itself that can be a little
tricky though depending on the tumor
content and the number of copies of
chromosomes because a lot of these
genomes are very rearranged and complex
so you can't assume that it's deployed
and so a lot of it goes into figuring
out what the expected frequency would be
if it were germline or if it were
somatic it's not always clear cut
sometimes it is very clear cut and other
times it's not which is why we like
having it but we did validate it for
both
and I can go to the next question and
looks like the question is does the
bracket 1 and 2 gene method based
validation would be a good benchmark for
other panels I'm actually not quite sure
what you're asking
I'm sorry I don't actually quite
understand the question so this is the
person who submitted that ok so I'm
going to go to the next one but if you
want to write back and clarify i'm happy
to try to answer and so how successful
you to detecting translocation inversion
if it is very challenging to detect
translocations we actually have detected
them I didn't say that this is the best
method of doing that and actually what
we are working on now is actually moving
away from doing this using DNA capture
and going to an RNA based capture I
think it's much more robust doing it
that way we certainly can detect
translocations but I would not I think
that's probably the week as part of this
panel is that you're really looking for
a needle in a haystack I didn't go into
the methods of how we do is what we're
looking for chimeric read so we're do
paired end sequencing so we're looking
for where the reads are not with an
expected range of where they be from the
insert and so if they're reads are
mapping to two different chromosomes or
one the same chromosome but too far
apart then that gets put into a bucket
and then we do some more filtering but
basically you know our for sequencing an
average is 600 x were seeing and these
translocations we're seeing maybe 10 to
20 reads for that and so you're really
are looking for needle and haystack and
it's tough so I think be an RNA RNA
based approach is actually a better way
to go and that's where we're moving
towards okay um next we have a question
from FEMA come on at the University of
Kentucky that's what is the insurance
reimbursement rate for comprehensive
next generation sequencing panel yeah
that's a great question to actually I
don't really quite know thankfully for
me for us our painting think that
patient financial services at UCSD
handles all the billing we don't see any
of that but what I will say is
that generally my understanding is that
private insurance reimburses decently
they don't necessarily reimburse more
because your test costs more and you
have more genes it just reimburses for
doing a you know multigene test so
there's not a huge disability ation
between 70 genes and 400 it's pretty
much all the same rates that you're
going to get reimbursed Medicare a lot
of these is cancers as an older
population so a lot of these patients
are Medicare Medicare won't reimburse
any of this so it's not exactly a
money-making operation it's kind of more
of a decision least right now from
Medical Center to be you know it's more
of a pair of patient care initiative
rather than something that's going to
make money but you know it will follow I
think you need to do these and once we
start getting more and more data back in
terms of how it's helping to inform
decisions and how it's improving care
than the clinical utilities more
established for looking broadly because
by single gene is at first table that I
showed instead of doing single gene
testing but going to more comprehensive
look and seeing what the value add is
there then I think the reimbursement
will follow so it's not zero but it's
certainly not a hundred percent okay a
very good point if there are no more
questions I would like to once again
thank dr. Mari for her presentation do
you need final comments for us before we
meet nope just thank you so much for
tuning in and sorry my voice cut out of
you time we sounded fantastic thank you
again so before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast we
available for on-demand viewing until
november 2016 you receive an email from
bobrucz alerting you when this podcast
is available for replay and we encourage
you to share that announcement we are
colleagues hunan this today's web event
that's all we have for now today thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon bye bye